well you know in the in the modern world
uh if you have you're lucky if uh your
historical memory goes back to breakfast
yeah but in our case I mean people
you're right they don't know the facts
they think we're the uh belgians in the
Congo or the Dutch and Indonesia or some
British Colonials I don't know in some
other part of uh Africa and so on and of
course this is not the case
thank you
how much of the uh the mishigas there's
a word for you of uh the Middle East is
just uh people not really understanding
the history I've heard you talk about
the history of Israel many many times
but people not understanding that when
you talk about Judea and Samaria which
we now know as the West Bank Judea Jews
used to live there Bethlehem that's
where Jesus lived that this is not a
place that Jews are foreign from that
people simply don't understand the basic
history of the land
well you know in the in the modern world
uh if you have you're lucky if uh your
historical memory goes back to breakfast
yeah but in our case I mean people
you're right they don't know the facts
they think we're the uh belgians in the
Congo or the Dutch and Indonesia or some
British Colonials I don't know in some
other part of uh Africa and so on and of
course this is not the case as you say
Jews came from Judea uh King David uh
it's been our homeland for 3 500 years
3000 years ago King David proclaimed
Jerusalem as our Capital the events
described in the Bible uh occurred for a
period of about two thousand years
actually less but about 1500 years until
the birth of just before the birth of
Christianity now where did that happen
where did Jesus turn over the uh the
tables of the money changers it wasn't
in a temple in Tibet I don't know all
right next to joburg in South Africa it
happened right there in Jerusalem uh and
what did what language did Jesus Jesus
speak he spoke Hebrew and he spoke
Aramaic he probably wrote in Hebrew and
so on his name is a Hebrew name he was a
Jewish rabbi from the Galilee so there's
an attempt to erase the first roughly 2
000 years of Jewish history it didn't
exist the Jews were not there well we
were in the original uh natives of the
land and actually we were dispossessed
you know all these conquerors people who
conquered us the Romans and before them
the Greeks and after the byzantines and
so on none of them displaced us actually
the displacement of the Jews from their
Homeland took place uh in greater
numbers and in significant numbers
after the Arabs conquered the land in
the 7th Century okay so it's not the
Arabs were the ones who uh who
expropriated the land from the Jews and
the Jews didn't expropriate from the
Arabs well that happens so what you're
gonna go back uh now 1300 years to the
7th Century the Arabs came in they lived
there it's their land no that's not what
happened
the Arab Conquest didn't populate the
land they didn't build new cities except
one communities one one
everything else was left Barren and they
too were displaced by other
conquerors other mom looks the
Ottomans the British at the end I don't
I won't get into that but a succession
of Empires govern this land
and it was nothing it wasn't the
homeland of anyone except the Jews who
never gave up the dream of coming back
to there and over the centuries Jews
would pray next year in Jerusalem next
year in Jerusalem and it was only in the
19th century when a modern Moses emerged
from for our people his name was
Theodore or herzo he was 36 years old
and he worked for only for eight years
that's it for eight years a giant of
history and because he died young at 44.
and he said the only way to have
National salvation uh and to avoid what
he foresaw would be the Holocaust in
Europe would be for the Jewish people to
come back to their ancestral Homeland
that return that began in the latter
part of the 19th century
uh brought the land back to life and as
we were bringing it back to life there
were people living there but very few uh
but the there was a great influx that
came in as a result of the Jewish return
influx of Arabs who came into better
wages for the factories for the uh
hospitals uh for the uh Farms that the
Jews built that attracted many Arabs
they now call themselves Palestinians
they say we've been here for thousands
of years you know from the time of Jesus
no they won we had a burdened Homeland
when the Jews came here in the 19th
century no you didn't Mark Twain will
attest to that and hundreds yeah nothing
you had nothing there we came back to
our ancestral Homeland rebuilt it
accepted the our Arab neighbors but they
refused to have ours and they still
refused so if you want to understand the
Justice of the Jewish case is we never
gave up our claim to our homeland we are
the native uh owners of the land we are
the ones who have every right to live
there uh having been dispossessed from
it first of all by Arabs but we don't
want to dispossess the Arabs themselves
they're the ones who refuse to do it and
if you ask me what is the persistent
obstacle
to having an israeli-palestinian piece
as opposed to
an Israeli arabies which we're achieving
it's the persistent Palestinian refusal
to recognize a Jewish state in any
boundary that's the problem and because
that's not going to be resolved right
away I say go to the Arab world get
these extraordinary agreements with the
Arab countries
and The Greatest Prize would be without
a doubt Saudi Arabia which would
effectively peace with Saudi Arabia
would effectively end the arab-israeli
conflict and then do your damnedest to
get the rejectionist leadership uh in
the Palestinian world uh Palestinian
Society to accept the right of the
Jewish people to have a state of their
own and then I think we can have a
solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict but I think
it's I think that's going to be the
order I had to change a perception that
had been ingrained in the minds of the
experts and the one
mavens and you name them you know for
for close to half a century I simply
challenged it and I was the think tank
people in DC probably were not that
thrilled with you the think tank people
in Tel Aviv went through it and
basically you know I have an idea that
all think tanks and many diplomats are
all produced in a secret plant 30
kilometers west of Luxembourg and then
they're sort of sent dispatched to all
the the bureaucracies the foreign policy
bureaucracy of the world then they just
chant this thing the Palestinian
conflict is the center of the is the
core of the conflict always in the
singular in the Middle East no it's not
uh the only way you can solve it is for
Israel to become so weak that it
couldn't defend itself no it's not
there's not going to be peace with the
rest of the Arab world if you don't
solve the palestinian-israeli conflict
no it's not but you know if you vest
yourself in this nonsense for decades
it's very hard to uh very hard to uh
detach yourself from it and so I always
find it I always find it interesting how
how it sort of mainstreams itself in a
bizarre sense so for example you know
Rashida Talib our congresswoman in
Michigan who I have no doubt you're not
a big fan of I think maybe she was even
banned from Israel at one point you know
show every uh December she wishes Jews a
happy Hanukkah but at the same time she
doesn't want Jews living in the place
that is the story of Hanukkah does she
know about the hills probably about two
miles from you right now
happy Hanukkah you know Hanukkah was
celebrated the victory of the Brave
Maccabees against one of the conquerors
of our land uh actually 2200 years ago
roughly 2 200 years ago 2 200 years ago
Jews were fighting for their freedom
against the uh basically the uh the
Celica the Empire which was based in
Syria one of the uh uh it's named after
one of the generals of Alexander the
Great uh who actually had a positive uh
attitude towards Jews but is uh
inheritors didn't uh and uh one of them
wanted to wipe out the Jewish religion
and Jews rebelled and this Rebellion uh
led by by Brothers
who each died they all died in this
battle finally achieved The Liberation
of the land and the liberation of
Jerusalem that's what we celebrate the
uh Hanukkah is the liberation of
Jerusalem specifically the cleansing of
the uh the Jewish temple uh so you tell
that to received I want to hear a
response so were the Jews there or not
were the Palestinians they're in
Hanukkah or the Jews were there in
Hanukkah you know and it exemplifies the
the tremendous ignorance that you you
discuss they just don't know the Jews
the Jewish people are probably one of
the oldest civilizations are not
probably Eric one of the two or three
oldest civilizations in history our
attachment to our ancestral Homeland is
unmatched uh a lot of people are
attached to their ancestral Homeland but
they're not as old as us and a lot of
them lost their ancestral Homeland and
disappeared we're the only ones who were
kicked out of it uh expelled from it and
said we're going to come back back and
we came back to find the odds of History
achieve this miracle build this
extraordinarily uh modern uh successful
State we respect Our Roots we respect
our neighbors
and we're bringing a light on to the
nation's principally by incredible
technology and yet they say you have no
right to live there you know we kicked
you out once we'll kick you out again no
you won't it won't happen whether you're
a Hamas or a Hezbollah or Iran it's not
going to happen we're not going to let
it happen if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues instead of
non-stop yelling check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell